hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
who are you hi I'm Paula Demi Paula
Deming and I have taught for 2.5 hours
yes and now we're here to react to some
videos I know long it's the way most
people respond to me in general I am
excited that you're back Paula hey I
just showed her the frozen 2 trailer the
first time she's ever watched it now I'm
gonna introduce her to something very
different that we love
have you seen Aldo Jones's weird
trailers no no she hasn't yes I'm not
gonna tell you they're just weird ass
parodies of this trailers ok that's all
that's all you get it now now that you
have seen the frozen 2 trailer you're
all impacted now don't be nervous this
is this is gonna be something special
Aldo specifically message us and said I
want you guys to check this out and I
said yay
we're doing it headphones Paula oh yeah
I follow Paula on Instagram and Twitter
and also she's part of fan theory TV you
guys should go check that out reactions
and stuff to Doctor Who if you're a
Doctor Who fan
now I know why she's running into the
water
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh man
[Music]
but a beautiful just a visually
beautiful trailer and just making just
destroyed right I mean that's what he
does best they're like I usually only
watch like his superhero ones they just
feel like Avengers or Captain you know
what I mean any of the superhero once
but it's a c4 a Disney one or like you
get some different jokes like some of
these are callbacks I could tobey
maguire face he loves throwing and Tobey
Maguire from spider-man 3 in there but a
lot of these inserts the fun thing about
Aldo Jones and I love introducing people
to him is because you can re-watch these
videos and you'll notice there are
things that you just did not pick up on
the first time he's got like those kind
of videos because when we watched the
trailer the real trailer I was like I
don't understand why she's running into
the water and in this version I'm like
oh okay I get it
if Jason Momoa is in the water I'd go
running here's the water - take off your
shoes and pull back your hair and just
[Laughter]
unfortunately not seems like it kept
changing the plot of this kept changing
a lot brilliant stuff the rock in the
water and the Ice Age bit the Avengers
running shot there's even more here's
earth I didn't even know tit now that
I'm slowing it down you got Shrek in the
background flash Alicia vikander from -
later as Laura Croft you got Ben Affleck
Superman over there
the Olaf hate train has definitely come
I feel like it's kind of valid it'd you
see Coco in the theaters I didn't see it
in the theaters but I did see it on a
bigger screen on like a projection
screen
did you see the Olaf adventure thingy
yeah that was I think that's why for the
frozen mart even in the trailer itself
there's like close to no Olaf in there
just the background of him you know yeah
so I think people are kind of sick of
him but you like him I like him I just
think his song in the first in the first
frozen is funny that's like my style of
humor personally I would have I would
have had just melted the get him out of
frozen he's ruining things but I like
the performer Josh GAD and all yes of
course Josh you're lovely Josh Josh
shopping person watches this channel
frequently sure he does and hey thanks
for being here leave a comment below
first josh thank you Thank You Josh yeah
I don't hate your carrot I don't hate
you I hate your character there's a
difference that's what I really loved
the shot at the very end when she turns
around and grabs the sword and it was a
lightsaber yeah slide apart I'm half
hoping that the actual movie she does
kill hold off in that scene and that's
what the whole teaser because you're
like what she's slicing at here with all
this darkness stuff going on yeah well
this is another great job
Aalto I'm proud of you for doing this
buddy you guys should go subscribe to
his page check out his patreon page
while you're at it too and speaking of
patreon I'd like to give a patient ad a
shout-out to one of our patrons if you
don't mind
no please who is it this is RuPaul
announcer head to all the things I'm
about to say bro and Maxon Bruin is a
handsome gentleman from Australia who
talks an awful lot about personal
development him and I have had quite a
lot of exchanges of monologues back and
forth broen you're the kind of guy who
stays pledged to our patreon sends me
monologues and then out of nowhere you
sort of just vanish and I don't know
where you've been I don't know why you
haven't replied back to me in a long
last time you're getting ghosted I think
I'm getting ghosted but his pledge is
still on patreon so it's the best kind
of ghosting that a guy can actually
indoor has that been ghosted an awful
lot in my life I can yes and thanks
would ever do that
what what is who would ever do that to
you I would never are you sure seems
like you're pretty confident I'm the
kind of you know what why don't you just
go hang out with broen talk about why
you guys are ghosting Jesus bro reply
back to me if not stay pledged please
thank you if only every girl who ever
goes to me stay pledged to my patreon
subscribers rejection click that
notification bell follow Paula on social
medias and fan theory TV where she's
reacting a Doctor Who with a lovely girl
named Katrina yeah will be my friend one
day yes hi Katrina